have you ever wondered why extremely
rich people buy very expensive art
pieces
well there could be many reasons like
love for art status investment tax
saving etc
in this video let us throw some light on
how they can save taxes
we know that other assets like houses
have limitations in value or have
benchmarks
but in the case of paintings there is no
true valuation now what does that mean
this means they can pay any amount of
money for the paintings they wish to buy
let's understand this with an example
let's say a super rich person buys a
very rare painting worth 10 million
dollars from the auction market
one spot they generally do not hang them
at their homes or offices
they immediately transfer it to free
ports and store them there
wait what are free ports a free port is
a place where the normal tax system and
customs rules are not applicable it's
like a free trade zone now as long as
this painting is sold from these free
trade zones no taxes will be involved
fast forward let's say the painting is
now estimated to be worth 25 million
dollars the person will now simply
donate the painting to a museum and get
a tax write-off of 25 million dollars
because it is now considered to be
charity
so on the investment of 10 million
dollars the person saved 15 million
dollars in the form of taxes
amazing right did you know that in some
countries you can keep your expensive
paintings with you even if you go
bankrupt
read the first comment to know more